not everyone wants to see you succeed
some will even go out of their way to
see you fail
learn to be sufficient
and realize you are Immortal who will
suffer horribly later
if you don't become independent and
resourceful
stop worrying about what other people
think
honestly
who gives a [__]
keep to yourself
stay away from idiots
stupidity is contagious
your friends want you to do good but not
better than them
rest don't care
learn how to say [__] it
and mean it
don't say yes to everyone to make them
comfortable
check with yourself too before you
commit
many people don't like you
especially if they see you as a
competition
rule your life with your mind
not with your feelings
every bad decision we have made in life
there was more emotion in it than there
was mind every single one
always listen to your gut
somehow it knows many things that you
wouldn't expect
know your worth
never put yourself in The Bargain Bin
or that's where others will value you
time truly flies
be grateful always because it can always
be worse
live like there's no tomorrow
and do what you love
don't get bogged down in regrets
no one is perfect
don't chase happiness just stay positive
and you will experience Joy
pay close attention to those who say
they love you
because so often they don't
they only use you
trust in yourself and your first
instinct on decisions
lower your expectations
having high expectations of yourself and
of others is a recipe for chronic
dissatisfaction in life
except that some folks love to point
fingers and blame others
you will be blamed for things you
haven't done
and for things that haven't even
happened yet
stop complaining whining and nagging
it's wasted energy
who's listening anyway
realize you cannot control everything or
everyone
but you can control yourself
and that's even better
always move in your own Direction
not according to society friends or
family
leave the house messy in the yard
unmowed for the weekend
you will remember the fun not the clean
house or yard
make time for fun
learn to say no
frugal
eat only real food no wheat and limit
carbs
the more you know the Dumber you sound
to stupid people
pay attention to the negative signs that
people give off and immediately
disconnect from them
it will save you a lot of pain and more
importantly
wasted time
never take the responsibility that does
not belong to you
never sell out and trust your instincts
also most importantly
never take loved ones for granted
have firm boundaries and be Discerning
about who you let into your life
if you want to help yourself
find someone worthy to serve
through service you gain experience
contacts
and a reputation as a reliable and
accountable Ally
it is only through an apprenticeship
that one becomes a master
by real estate land
anything you can afford
the less possessions you own
the happier and less burden you will
have in your life
is often very ambiguous
sometimes there isn't a right or wrong
decision or choice
things are not always completely clear
you may not get the answer so you just
have to wing it
don't leave someone to teach them a
lesson
leave because you learned yours
life is far from over
but it's very short too
if you want to do something don't delay
but don't sacrifice what you want for
what you want right now
when in doubt just take the next small
step
they can keep friends with the people
you want to emulate
not the people that you think will be
most likely to accept you
the people you associate with Will shape
your future
careful who you marry
and even more careful who you have kids
with
slow down and realize that mistakes are
essential to learning anything
get yourself together before you get any
older
the older you are the harder it is to
change
no one cares except family
start saving your money
don't spend it on homes you can't afford
fancy cars and running your credit cards
to the max
in the end
you'll be much happier
nothing is actually as bad as it seems
or as great as you think it will be
take good care of your health
without Health nothing will matter
no amount of money can bring you Joy if
you are suffering
hurry before Thirty have kids before 35.
work and earn actively and sufficiently
till and before 40.
make passive income workable before 50.
plan to retire from work activity before
60.
do everything for family but expect
nothing from it
not even from spouse
you'll never be sorry for telling
someone you love them
do it before it's too late
save a little money every week or month
nothing gives you happiness like a
financial buffer believe it or not
if it ain't broke
don't fix it
not everybody wants to be your friend
and that's okay
you really don't want everybody as a
friend anyway
you don't always have to be going being
and doing
it's really okay to just
chill
give back
even if it's donating your tag sale
leftovers or handing a dollar bill over
to someone less fortunate
do it
it'll make you feel good
everything happens for a reason
always
do not fear getting hurt
you can't grow if you don't hurt
don't ruin your health in order to earn
money
you will end up spending your money to
recover your health
and that
is not reciprocal
be kind to people without allowing them
to take advantage of your good nature
efforts never go in vain
how others see you is not important
how you see yourself
means everything
the only way to live like a king
is to work like a slave
everything you need will come to you at
the perfect time
you came into this huge world alone
and we'll go out of it
alone
hence can make any impossible thing
possible
by yourself only
punish the truth
expect to be lied to
you will look back at your life with
much more regret for the things that you
didn't do
than for the things that you did
things don't make us happy
experiences do
keep your mouth shut whenever you are
happy
keep your mouth shut
whenever you are sad
stop comparing yourself with those who
started 10 years before you
focus on your own Journey
you can't go back and change the
beginning
but you can start where you are and
change the ending
if you waste money you can earn it again
if you miss the moment it can never be
returned
live life with opened eyes ears and
heart
strong people are always simple
you spend your first 20 years worrying
what people think about you
you spend your next 20 years swearing
that you don't care what people think
about you
you spend the next 20 years realizing
that they aren't thinking about you
never let others know your weaknesses
instead always try to show up your
positives
don't tell your friends that you're
happy
don't make them angry
don't tell your enemies that you're
unhappy
don't make them happy
time flies
one day you are 30 the next you are 50.
plan now for what you want 50 to look
like
last but not least
you are here for a reason that you may
not know
but be patient you beat a billion odds
by being here
be grateful for the little things in
life that others take for granted